good evening one of the hardest hit
groups during the pandemic has been the
latino community
thanks for staying with us here at 6 30
i'm denise valdis and i'm brian loftis
now that info according to a new recent
report which states they have taken both
a personal
and financial toll christian casares
joining us live in studio with that
story
that's right guys well it's data we have
seen play out over the past
year many latinos claim the hit was
harder for them because many
are essential workers and the risks are
higher
you knew it was around but
until it touches you you don't really
feel it
it's been over a year since jeanette's
and malina lumbres passed away from
covet 19.
she worked in the medical field and
jeanette says that
increased her exposure to the virus i
remember she didn't want
she could barely get out of bed and
she was actually getting oxygen at the
time
because she would get some coughing fits
where she just couldn't stop coughing
and
she didn't even want us to come near her
she was just like
you know i'll just stay over here and
you guys you know you guys visit with
your grandmother but i'm so happy that i
got to see you
and i didn't know that was going to be
the last time i got to see her
but she's not alone recent data from the
pew research center
surveyed more than 3 300 hispanic adults
in march
half reported that someone close to them
had either been hospitalized
or died from the virus senator catherine
cortez-mastro says
the key turning that around is education
if we bring the mobile vaccination sites
into the communities meet the people
where they are data also showed 45
percent of latino adults had jobs that
required them to work
outside the home since the pandemic
started however
65 percent said the worst is behind us
now with the coveted relief packages
that i tried for to make those
investments in our community to beat
this pandemic
we are able now to really open up our
economy again
financially half of latinos surveyed
claimed to have a loss in wage
or jobs i felt so helpless elena's death
caused their grandmother to move in with
other relatives and a big push to get
vaccinated
well jeanette's aunt was living with her
grandmother who also tested positive for
covid but
she survived now during quarantine the
grandmother received assistance with
groceries and other things through the
church community
a similar act that many latinos reported
in the survey
christian castle is 8 news now